este 75 aniversario de la Nava o
catástrofe en árabe Está marcado por un
hecho inédito por primera vez en
Naciones Unidas se conmemora de manera
oficial esta fecha en la que los
palestinos recuerdan El Éxodo forzado de
unas 750.000 personas tras la creación
del estado de Israel el presidente de la
autoridad Palestina además Judas está en
Nueva York para brindar un discurso en
este evento al que el embajador israelí
ante la ONU calificó de abominación y
llamó a boicotearlo Estados Unidos es
uno de los países por ejemplo que
anticipó que no va a participar de la
ceremonia por su parte ramala fue el
epicentro de la movilización principal
que incluyó una conmemoración con el
sonar de las sirenas durante 75 segundos
para los palestinos o no se trata solo
de reivindicar El derecho al retorno de
los refugiados hoy estimados en unos
seis millones en distribuidos entre
territorios palestinos y países vecinos
como Siria o Líbano sino también que
denuncian lo que llaman una Nava en
curso por el desalojo y la destrucción
de El Avance de los asentamientos
israelíes en sij Jordania ocupada y la
pérdida de Vidas precisamente hoy en una
nueva redada del ejército israelí en la
blusa un joven de 22 años murió por
disparos y Este joven fue reivindicado
como miembro de las hijas islámica
Palestina todo esto se da en un año que
ya es el más violento desde la segunda
intifada con más de 140 palestinos
muertos en sí Jordania ocupada por fuego
israelí y unas y un total de 19 personas
muertas del lado israelí en ataques de
palestinos también se da dos días
después del César fuego entre Israel y
las milicias de gaza que en cinco días
de enfrentamientos dejaron un total de
35 muertos y tres días antes de la
denominada marcha de las banderas el
desfile anual de ultranacionalistas
judíos que conmemoran en la toma israelí
de Jerusalén este y que es considerado
una provocación por los palestinos